foreign
yeah so which degree D polynomials are
close to Boolean
so we need to State the question I will
need to explain what do I mean by
degrees polynomials and what do I mean
by close to Boolean so we'll start with
some more classical stuff and then we'll
do less classical stuff
Okay so
I guess the first result maybe in an
analysis of worrying functions is the
KKL theorem I think historically like if
you look at the earliest is that true
but then the second result is that this
feedback Lionel theorem from 2002
which originally it was uh
um
has this quantitative version of Arrow
serum and there was a question about
if you're almost satisfied the
constraints of error's theorem and what
does your social Choice function look
like anyway so there was some actual
motivation behind this
so here's the Afghan theorem
all right so if
f is a degree
one
F from zero one
again to the reals
is a degree one function
and this is close the volume in the
following sense
okay
then
f is order Epsilon
close
to a constant
or a dictator
okay so what's going on here so we have
a function the input is n Bits in zero
one and the output is a real number
it's degree one this means that you can
express it as a degree one polynomial in
the inputs okay
and it's close to Boolean in an L2 sense
this means that if you look at each
point they look at the square distance
from zero or one like the one which is
closest
and you take expectation that you get
something small
yeah so which functions satisfies this
so if Epsilon is equal to zero so your
function is boiling on all points then
we have the zero function the one
function the x i and one minus x i
and what this Afghan theorem States is
that even if you're just close to
Boiling this L2 sense then still the
only way that you can accomplish this is
by being close to one of these Boolean
degree one functions
okay so this is considered by some to be
a fundamental theorem in this area
others like there's somebody here who I
mentioned the apparent theorem and they
said ah what's what is this so
apparently for the new comment it's no
longer necessary yeah
or
yeah the original proof is
hyperconductivity but actually in guys
see this there's an inductive proof and
also the paper had a mistake which a guy
pointed out and corrected so yeah and I
want to see a guy's name again
okay so the degree digitalization
this is uh the
esopha theorem
okay so this is guy and this is
just the same thing for degree d
so if f
working from zero one to the N to the
real numbers
uh is a degree D function
and
F is Epsilon close to Boolean
so I'm not going to copy it again
okay
is order Epsilon
rows to
uh
Boolean
degree
e function okay so we don't really have
a a nice list of these functions for D
larger than 2 for D equals two we can do
it but
internal but what you can say
is that the only way to be close to
Boolean is if you're actually close to
one of these Boolean degree D functions
and in particular you're close to a
Honda so you really
secretly you depend only on a small
number of variables how small we have we
are here uh improved some parameters
is how small
yeah so you won't find this theorem
listed in the paper for two reasons one
reason is that there is no paper so
okay there are some drafts available on
the author's website they're not the
same
there is a published but not a refereed
version in guys thesis
okay
there is now a published version in the
state of color and crime so if you can
if you want to cite it and you want an
actual paper then you can actually do it
now
and I also have some many proofs on my
website
um yeah it's also not stated this way
but it's still true
okay
I would say it should be interpreters
are also for a movie but
that's what just my opinion
okay so this this gives one answer to
this uh which liquidity Point numbers
are close to Boolean
maybe nobody asked but I'm taking the
expectation over X so what is the
distribution of x
distribution of X yeah yes
what the distribution effects
uniform yeah
so um but it makes a big difference
um
so what we're going to do in the rest of
the talk we're going to to discuss uh
two different distributions on the
inputs okay
so the rest of the stock
okay so we're going to discuss two
domains so the first domain is the
P bias Cube
now which I'm going to go over what this
means in a bit
and the other one is the symmetric group
and we're going to ask this question for
these two domains and we're going to get
some answers not all of them but some of
them
okay
now I should say that um
yes we'll transpired this is really
about the structural function so I think
it's a good fit for the theme of this
workshop and this semester
yeah so what is the P bias Cube and why
do we care about it um
so the people ask you if it's we still
have any inputs
but now the whenever we say that
something is close to something else oh
yeah I didn't say but this is also in an
L2 sense also I didn't say it here
so f is order Epsilon closer function
means that the
application of
f of x minus G of x
squared is uh order Epsilon of course
where G is a constant or dictator
yeah so in all these expectations we can
instead of considering the uniform
distribution we can consider this P bias
distribution
where every point is equal to one with
probability p
so this is the distribution mu B
so mu P of x
there's P to the
on my x i there's one minus P to the sum
I 1 minus x i okay so this corresponds
exactly to this errors any random graph
for example
yeah so you put in each probability p is
the same thing only now we don't have a
graph just unstructured input
so this is um
kind of an important distribution like
let's say one of the
most celebrated results outside of the
series of this area proper is the free
Goods sharp threshold term
or Bergen's appendix or A hermits or
whatever so there are a bunch of them
and this is exactly in this setting
um where we think of p as small so FP is
constant then all of these results that
they still hold
yeah maybe you have to change the proof
but like it's essentially the same thing
or maybe they're also even a reduction
in this Nathan kind of business
but when P small then we see a phenomena
that we don't see from constant P so for
example this chart threshold business so
when p is not small then
the corresponding structure is a Honda
and when p is more then it's a lot more
elaborate
okay and that's what we're going to see
here as well
okay so this is the P bias Cube
what is a symmetric group we all know
it's the group of alternations of n
elements but here's how I want to think
about it so
a symmetric group is
set of all
n by n primitation matrices
foreign
so we have this N squared or n by an
array of inputs which I call x i j each
of them is 0 1 there's exactly one one
in every Row in column
and this also gives you a definition of
degree
so a function is degree D if you can
write it as a degree table polynomial
okay and then you can ask the same
questions and hope maybe for an
enlightening answer
okay
so the first thing we're going to start
with is with the p biased fkn theorem
so this will be the FK NTM for short
and this is a good opportunity to
mention that
prefers his name red this way but even
Israelis don't do it so if you say color
it's fine
so people have a right to choose how
they pronounce their name
so here's a statement of the pre-bio
store rather the beginning of the
statement of the p-biased fdn theorem
Ias
KN here
so we let P be at most a half a if p is
more than half then let's just switch
zeros and ones on the big deal
if f
I want to be on mu p
r
as
degree one
and
is Epsilon close
to Boolean
and
F or 1 minus f is order Epsilon
Mouse to
what
yes I already gave you some of the
answer because like I'm doing f one
minus F but let's not worry about it
yeah so maybe uh the first guess
would be that
you have to be close to the same thing
as here to a constant or a dictator
and this is kind of true but also kind
of false
and we'll see in a moment in what sense
it's true and in what sense it's less
true
yeah so are there other functions other
than these constants or dictators that
are also close to linear functions
maybe somebody can think of a function
like this
so if you do if p is 1 by n can you take
or
yeah
so I'm not taking more because R is
another problem
yeah
yeah so that's a very good obligation
so here's a suggestion
we take uh X Y 1 plus
x i Am
where
okay so when B is equal to one over n
then yeah we can do it we can just take
some for everything but when p is one
half and we're only something over one
thing
okay so what's the difference
how does this thing behave what is the
distribution of this roughly
so each of them is a Bernoulli P random
variable and we're summing M of them
yeah so roughly poisson MP
then what's the probability that the
poisson MP is not 0 1.
it's not a trick question
okay what's the probability that the
poisson random variable is equal to zero
Okay so
some people here are expert in
statistics so they should know this
like e to the minus MP
roughly 1 minus MP
so it's equal to one with probability
MP times e to the minus MP which is
roughly
and V and it's equal to
2 with probability
of MP
word over 2
to the minus MP which is roughly
MP squared
over two and
yeah so as we take our higher and higher
numbers than we get even less and less
probability
so the probability that that we're not
bullying is is roughly MP squared
okay
so this means that we need MP
the Vietnam
if you want to be absolutely
anyway m is Atmos one or M is the
smallest Square Capital over p
okay we just did the calculation yeah
and we didn't really do it all the end
because
so this will work for like l0 and we
need L2 let's not worry about these
things as they work out
yeah so this is a theorem and it has an
interesting uh Corollary
okay so f is
order square with Epsilon
close to a constant or a dictator
and Order square root Epsilon
the speed close
to a constant
I hope you can still see
if not then well said it
yeah so
that's why I said that this guess is
both true and false
so it is true that if even when p is
small
then you are still close to a constant
or a dictator but you're not Epsilon
close you're only Square tips on clothes
so in many many applications we don't
really care
right Epsilon Square Epsilon the same
thing even like something which is like
inverse Tower is good enough for us
but maybe from a structural perspective
we look here and and then when we look
at it with this magnifying glass of up
to order Epsilon error then you get this
more refined structure
and you can also say so if I think of p
as small then maybe this thing is like
very small and it really says that the
only way that a function like this can
be close to to Boolean is if it's
essentially a constant
okay so kind of the question is not so
interesting because like if the function
is zero
yeah so I'm describing the class of
function which are essentially zero
yeah but I I don't know
um of any direct proof of this
I mean maybe there is but
okay so this is the the P bias fkm
theorem
and what we're going to do next is we're
going to look at the symmetric group and
see what happens there this will be
slightly more interesting
but it will be very similar yeah
[Music]
the slice of specific language
everything goes through
yeah so actually this paper is
originally written from size
but now we know things to work as long
that the right way to look at the slides
is use this coupling with the previous
queue
this works unless like the slides the
weight is very very very small
or anything then there's no reason to
say about the slice at all because you
can just apply this coupling and you've
got the same result that you get from
the P by C with P which is the weight
over n
and if you're insist you can also do it
directly on slides
should last give yourself
yeah we'll get to that that will be the
third thing
maybe the most interesting here
so you have to uh keep the suspense
okay
so yeah let's erase this
okay more questions
symmetrical this is really kind of a
question that um
more related to the previous Workshop
hey I was saying that we're losing
regulations yeah
this addiction is the main topic of the
stuff is
can you say something about this
uh yeah I'm saying yeah because the
troops are all the same but I can say
something now it's just a reduction to
the Android space
and that hopefully it'll be time to tell
you how you do it like whatever
you can also very similar directly using
uh Global hyper connectivity but I
suspect that you should do it directly
then we won't get that to them yeah
so okay and
here for SM
but before that maybe we should ask
ourselves what happens uh if Epsilon is
zero so if we have just a Boolean degree
one function
oh there's a theorem
of
um
David Ellis
and until
[Music]
it means uh pepper peppercorn it's a
really stupid name
so that's not the original name so one
of these names that they changed when
they came to Israel to be more patriotic
or something not something called
something else foreign
to zero one
has degree one
and
f is uh
dictator
because I haven't said anything because
I didn't say what the dictator is you
can define a dictator that sends a
Boolean integral on function
yeah so what what can you do
which functions are exactly the green
one
exactly not people who don't know yes
right exactly
so so there are two forms either you do
something like this x i j one plus
x i j m
or you do
x i one J plus plus x i n
J
or pictorially if this is a permutation
then either your son something along the
same row or something along the same
column
yeah this is proved using the berkov
polytope
okay so now and you can guess what the
the interior will say
so we'll start with the Corollary
so this is a corollary of the theorem
okay
f f s n to R
as degree one
and is
Epsilon close to Boolean
and
it is order square with Epsilon
close to a dictator
so maybe
um yeah it's striking it's really the
same thing
foreign
because like you're close to zero in
this case you're close to a dictator so
it can actually be close to many
different functions
so it's not a vacuole statement
right
but you can also if you care about this
you can look at the
structure up to an area of order Epsilon
and here like there's some historical
background so
ten years ago I can't remember
we had some papers with David Alice and
a good fruit but about this question and
we got some partial results and then we
all forgot about it and now
suddenly this came up again and um
yeah so now we have the optimal answer
that you'll see in a moment but some of
the other people don't care as much now
so
they moved on but I'm so telling it to
you maybe you you will care more
so
the structure is going to be the same as
here so we're going to sum these x i J's
another question is uh here the
condition is that you're not summing too
many of them
so what is the corresponding condition
for uh for permutations
so this will be the actual theorem
it's under the same conditions
F or one minus f
is order Epsilon
close
to a sum
of
x i Js
where so here there will be some
constraints
okay so what are the constraints so we
can try to do the same calculation that
we did here
Okay so
let me erase this
foreign
x i m j m
and we want this thing to be
um non-boyant with probability Epsilon
okay so let's try to
to estimate what's the probability that
this thing is non-bullying
so for this to be known volume we need
to have two of these uh summons which
evaluate to one at the same time
okay so we will say that
x i j
x i y J Bar
a conflicting prayer
maybe not the best terminology
if I is different from I bar and J is
different from J Bar
yeah so yeah maybe it's not the best
terminology but let's watch in the paper
so it's too late now
so it's completing me if they can both
occur together you can think maybe it
should be exactly the opposite right but
I think it's conflicting because it
makes them non-bullying
yeah we'll have a different name for it
for the Kindle Shuffle theorem so
Okay so
your probability of being non-bullying
with most like number of conflicting
pairs
however
and N minus one this is the probability
of hitting uh both of these uh
x i j and x i bar J Bar
so we want this thing to be at most
Epsilon so we want to have
our
order Epsilon N squared conflicting
pairs
and there's another technical condition
that will be only a few of these uh x i
J's
yeah only order and many
and moreover
[Music]
all such functions
are order Epsilon close to Boolean
okay so again so in this setting you're
going to be either F or Y minus f is
going to be close to some of these x i
J's so sum of coordinates
sum of not too many of them so for a
dictator we need at most n or create
most n minus one so here I promise you
it moves the order n
and there are not so many conflicting
pairs so this is this uh back of the
envelope calculation
okay so this is the structure that I
promised you and it so happens that if
you have a function that is of this form
then it's also all your Epsilon close to
Boolean so in this sense the structure
is typed
yeah it's like something a bit technical
so this will be this is related to
spreadness globalness all these
properties
so yeah I try to find this example that
shows that if you don't assume that then
this is false and like the calculation
didn't work out
but kind of what's happening is um
if you had many many different uh so
many many different things then maybe
um
I think we'll add up and you'll still be
at distance Epsilon in l0 from Boolean
but maybe the outer distance will be bad
yeah that's also possible
so you're saying we got it for free so
it's also possible
but we'll need this anyway because
you put it here explicitly but yeah it
might be right
yeah but this one
thing so
here we have an upper one so if you have
to look where it goes so if you have
only a small number of conflicting pairs
then you will be close to Boolean but
material distance of boiling is you can
reverse this this is like an approximate
equality up to culture factors
this is something we call the reverse
unit bound and
it kind of like some some kind of proxy
of sunflower business
yeah and now what's the point of having
this structure so we can prove the
corollary so I don't know if how to
prove the corollary directly
okay so this structure is useful for
something at least
yeah for the profile I might have more
time to say about it later but it's a
reduction to the volume Cube so it's the
same proof
it's a little bit more technical but
it's the same same basic idea
questions
that's the same result both if you
consider functions not the book not the
zero one but some point itself probably
yeah so I mean the people need some some
work but too early to be true so
what
yeah so these are The Disappearance here
in the pivot setting and this
degradation they work in this general
setting and it's not formulated like
this but
it's important some earlier version
[Music]
probably but it will require some
efforts yeah and even like the atomical
zero okay it's like it's not so clear
what exactly you'll get but yeah stock
permutation is not necessarily a natural
to consider zero one
um
yeah also actually mentioned in the
paper there also results for L1 distance
[Music]
there are many questions we can consider
and we
did something for your students
yeah but this is a good point in the
other papers that definitely do work
industry
yeah more questions
yeah
so uh
there are these functions used from sm01
yeah so okay so the reason that we
thought about this 10 years ago is
uh because of intersecting families of
fermentations this would be one way of
proving stability
uh even back then it was a different
better way and now there are even better
ways using the quota method
so that that's where these questions
came from but but you can think of this
as a
trying to generalize the study of the
Boolean Cube to other settings
yeah I can necessarily motivate these
particular results like they don't have
any immediate or any applications
but you could say that this is in our
natural question
you know the things that we said
that's why these applications to
stability
yeah but I think by now that we know how
to prove it in some other ways and also
back then you can prove better results
without using it
it was a fake application to begin with
but uh
yeah it was a good question like how do
you choose the topics that you work on
it
is
okay sure this is
yeah okay so there might be something
yeah but the frame of mind is uh do you
know some stuff and we sometimes care
about functions from other domains so
let's say
or my Grant application I wrote the
Craftsman scheme uh
High dimensional expenders I'm having
better pcps like you can make the case
not necessary for these results but for
some results
and like this is a lot of stuff that
Norm and Costa have been doing is
exactly this like not these without but
some other results
I don't have any application for them
now for the thing that you asked so the
final part will be the degree the case
of this
so this would be the
key minus
on top of here
not really one thing I should say
um this constant here doesn't depend on
P and this is of an entire point
it's a global concept
and this will be the same thing here
if you can depend on P then this proof
is just the same as the unbiased
very interesting it's independent
so let P be at most half
zero one to the n p
the wheels
the uh degree D function
which is
Epsilon close to Boolean
that's a degree function just means that
you can write it as a degree deployment
okay then
f is
um order Epsilon close
to a function
see such that so now we will have four
conditions
so GS degree
me
this way G has degree d
okay I'm going to get this zero because
uh it's kind of the point here
okay uh G of Y is in zero one
if
Y is it most d
is uh as far as 1 to us so I'm just
undefined
and
he has
order Epsilon over P to the e
minimal
non-bullying
[Music]
inputs
of weight
in just also something I will Define
okay
and moreover
such functions
or order Epsilon close
your Boolean
okay and the Corollary
f is
order Epsilon to the
ad
1 over 80.
close
to uh
Boolean degree D function
and Order Epsilon to the 1 over VD
plus b
close to constant
and this number
BD
we have a formula for it
is probably the same as BD but I
couldn't prove it so
yeah
okay so now what we'll do is
I'll explain to you what is this uh
sparse monster business uh like in
hindsight this is just redness
essentially
and I claim what is this a minimal
non-building input then we'll see uh how
it corresponds like what have happened
when D equals one why is the same as the
previous results
and then hopefully I'll have maybe a few
minutes to talk about the proof
yeah yeah so it's for Ollie but it turns
out that the minimum number and input
has bounded weight so
write down about it
I would never Define itself you can
imagine what it means
okay so maybe let me start with the
first condition so what does this tell
us sorry this yeah question number one
so if we look at the expansion of d as a
polynomial in the Y's it's others that
we know what are all the possible
coefficients
okay so let's take as an example
the degree one case
foreign
so in the degree 1 case
would be equal to one
for transition one so let's say that g
is C plus sum i c i y i
so what's what is this condition one say
so G of 0 is just C so this has to be 0
let's say
is equal to zero and now G of e i this
is the unit Vector with only um one a
single one
this is equal to c plus c i which is CI
this is the zero one
okay so we got the G is the sum or one
minus the sum
okay and in general like we will get all
the possible coefficients and we get
what we call a quantized polynomial
because the coefficients they come from
some are finite set okay now what is
this uh
let's do three first
so a minimal non-boy in input is just an
input of the function which is
um
well the function is not Boolean for
this input but if you replace them one
by zero then it is Boolean
okay so uh
why is a minimal
non-bullying input
if
G of Y is not in zero one
but G of Z
isn't zero one
for all Z that are
below y
EP okay I'll give an example so when d
is equal to one then we have essentially
one type of non-going input
so this would be uh
e i plus e j
e i plus C J
and c i and C J are equal to one
okay so this gives us this is some sort
of forbidden configuration it's not
really forbidden because we allow a bit
of it
but let's say here so here we said that
there there was a Bound in the number of
ends and here there was abundant number
of conflicting pairs and this
corresponds with some kind of bad
configuration that cannot occur occur
too much
and this bad configuration is a minimal
onboarding input like here it was just a
conflicting pair so this is
yeah this is uh we Define it as a
minimal number in input
and and here it says that
like X i1 and xi2 or rather ei1 Plus ei2
for example is this will be a minimum
non-boyant input of this function and we
can't have too many of them and that's
the reason that m is bounded
and the reason that we get this is
because otherwise the function wouldn't
be Epsilon close to Boolean
yeah so a minimum input is some input in
which the function is not Boolean but
it's minimal like um
yeah it's like well I don't know if I
can say it in any other way
s
oh
um
foreign
two so we look at
the support of G okay what's the support
of G this is the set of s
like that the coefficient
of
this monomial is non-zero
yeah
yeah that's what I wanted I want to
explain much as fast contact
okay yeah
the sense you're counting how many
depends
right
so this one can do the polynomial
and an ongoing input it doesn't enable
where the function is not Boolean
and it's minimal whenever you
with 100
becomes boiling
okay so as an example in this case
and just sum over all possible overall
inputs which are minimum let's see what
happens here
okay so how many uh
number input we have here so what's the
number and minimum that I'm going input
here it's Eid plus e i k okay so here
is this
so yeah
sorry for the rest
so if G is
that's y1 plus plus ym
then a non-boolean input a minimal
Y is a minimal
non-voying input
and on the f y is of the form e i plus e
j
where I and J are in
between 1 and M and different
okay so this is an input at which the
function is equal to two
but if you go down then you get zero or
one so it's Boolean
okay so how many inputs do we have so
the number
of these inputs
and choose two
yes I'm saying that the m2s2 needs to be
at most Epsilon over P Squared
you know either m is equal to zero one
and otherwise M22 is like N squared and
then M squared is the smallest Epsilon
over B squared so
m is at most vertication over p
and this is also the exactly the same
thing that we had
or the industrated for the symmetric
group so
P to the power e
sorry
yeah
yeah it's right here so it's the same
thing as here so a conflicting pair is
exactly the same thing as a minimum
Boolean input and
okay now we're good with this
okay so the support of G is the set of s
that is the coefficient of this monomial
is non-zero so we want support of G
we think of it as a hyper graph so
support of J
as uh
under 1 over P to the e
edges of weight
and the same
old
for all links
yeah if you don't know what the link is
and I just write out in the case D
equals two
so for D equals two
so we have all one over B
non-zero
c i
can order one over P Squared
non-zero
cij so this will be the coefficient of y
i y j
and for each I order one over P non-zero
c i J's
yeah so this is uh essentially the
spreadness condition whatever you want
to call it we called it usually some
other term but
and this we get for free or from the
proof and it's necessary to reverse some
unit on somewhere
like this so
let us not or worry too much about that
this is this condition we see it here
okay so in the interest of time let me
spend uh like a few minutes answering
every size question
how do we prove this because this will
be very easy
and then we'll open for other questions
so I'm sorry we were a bit in a rush
just because somebody actually asked
thank you
so I'm going to attend the proof of the
the films about the previous field but
the proof for the geometry group is
similar maybe it's slightly more
interesting
so we start our starting point is a
function f which is from 0 1 to the N mu
p
to R
where P that most have
now for every
yes
FS is
the restriction
to zero one
to the S obtained by
substituting
zeros
for the other coordinates
okay so now if
s is chosen according to Mu P mu 2p and
Y is chosen according to Mu half
of 0 1 to the s
and Y is chosen according the same thing
as it's using Y according to Mu P this
is the main observation it's not very
deep
yeah so one way to sample something
according to the P by distribution is
fair to sample something according to
the 2p device distribution and then to
sample it according to the one half
distribution so p is two P times half
this is uh the Deep observation here
yeah so
on average
FS is
belongs to
Boolean
okay and then we just apply the Afghan
theorem and the kind of software theorem
on these fs's and we somehow paste all
these things together we do this using
uh in the Afghan theorem it's very easy
and in the kind of software case we do
it using the agreement terms but there's
also a way not doing it this way
let's not worry about it
okay so we get by design that g so this
is the function we obtained by pasting
and maybe I should say
and so
do some GS
where GS is the function that is
promised to us by the fan theorem or the
kind of software theorem and we paste
all of these GSS to This Global function
G somehow
okay so by Design GS degree d
um this will essentially get because the
function Gs are Boolean
okay this we get well because of the way
we do the pasting and this we get
because the function is absolutely close
to Boolean
so what you actually can do is you do
mature majority of the coding so for
every coefficient you look at all the
gs's and what all the relevant GSS and
what value they give you that
coefficient and you choose the the
plurality
and this will work
so this is proof for symmetric group we
need to use a different
um
process
so we choose a random two random
permutations
to this and this to this or they map
a list of this and this to this and then
the same for the next pair and so on
okay so this gives us uh
so
a copy
of 0 1 to the
lower n over 2.
and now we apply this Afghan term and we
do the same thing so I said it in like a
few words but um
it's a similar idea
yeah open questions uh do this uh degree
D is a case for the geometric group and
maybe a more exciting open question is
uh do this in Q analogs like Grassman
scheme bilinear scheme where I think
though has some partial results
but we don't even know how to do the F1
equals zero case for these other domains
so we cannot no other thing we work and
one reason is all of these proofs they
reduce to the Boolean Cube and if you
cannot do it then we don't know what to
do we don't have any other technique
except for Global hyper connectivity
which is I guess what though he's doing
yeah so I guess I'm only over time so
I'll end here
yeah so there's another funny result
um so
yeah where the written functions on the
keyboard contacts but this is not the
case for slices if the void is very very
small
so you can take the function
s
here and take the function X1
G Plus x c plus one
two three plus
okay and if you're working on the slides
and choose scale or k is less than 2D
and this will be Boolean but not
important
and like I said to these Optimum so it
is at least 2D then you will get the
point and also have to in your
oppression this just gets a lot more
interesting if the alphabet is not zero
one then there is still a problem
so so this is one case where you cannot
do this you can compare it to the
previous View just because p is too
small
other questions
again
to take this opportunity to thank the
organizers and